when dick and i first met in the
beginning of the exorcist
neither one of us
was aware of the challenges ahead
for i was the cinderella girl in new
york
a child model i did happy commercials
had a little cherubic face ponytails
i was supposed to be
the next disney girl
well
when billy freaking cast me in the
exorcist
little did dick smith know what was in
store for him
he was asked to turn me into the ugliest
sickest scaly skin monster ever
to be exact
the devil himself
no problem for dick
he pops two straws in my nose
pours what looks like pancake batter all
over my head
and proceeds to wrap me like a mummy
with plaster strips
over the coming months
dick would proceed to cast every part of
my body
my eyes
my ears
my tongue
my feet my torso you name it he cast it
and he'd say now make an evil face and
hold it
make a happy face make a nothing face
and over and over and over
the problem was that our director billy
friedkin did not want me
to wear a mask
he wanted the audience to recognize my
face
he came to me one day and said if
the audience does not know it's you the
movie is a joke
so he proceeded to ask dick
to work over and over and eventually
what he did was he had the smallest of
pieces
that changed my eyebrows changed my face
did all the scarring effects and then he
painted and painted and we did
all of the
camera work over and over and rehearsed
and tested
until billy friedkin
got what he wanted
and that
took dick smith
an enormous amount of effort
for me
it was not as much fun
as i think it was for dick
and he got to put the color contacts in
my eyes he encouraged me how fun wearing
the big white out ones would be
he changed my teeth
my tongue
he put all kinds of
goo in my hair
it was not a little girl's dream
although we struggled daily with the
makeup and the equip equipment they
invented to turn my head around no i
really can't do that
to levitate me
throw me around and of course make me
vomit
on cue
despite all that dick became my friend
and most of all it was through our
mutual love
and respect
for animals
he would proceed to tell me many stories
while he was
putting on this
makeup
to keep me entertained and happy
and for that dick i am always very
grateful
what was
so hard for me to endure
so many years ago my friend
created a film that to this day
continues to entertain and confuse the
heck
out of audiences
worldwide
dick
it is truly
my honor
and my privilege
to have been one of the many people and
actors
that you transformed
and made movie magic
that i think forever changed the way we
look at film and the characters and the
work the actors do
in order
to bring
entertainment
to the people
around the world
dick it is my honor and privilege
to be part of this tonight
congratulations my friend you deserve
this for so many years and i'm proud to
be part of it i love you very much
you